quarante ans qu'ils regardent lit et
signe des documents depuis ses débuts
politiques dans les années 70 et guy
malandain a tout connu
conseiller général en 1976 député des
yvelines en 1981 dans la foulée de la
victoire de françois mitterrand il
découvre saint-quentin-en-yvelines deux
ans plus tard et rejoint alors alain
d'année le maire ps de l'époque à
elancourt
j'ai choisi elancourt parce que je le
rappelle la circonscription
couvrez couvre et rappels en cours vous
n'aurez pas plaisir et c'est donc une
très très grande partie de ce qu'était
la ville nouvelle à cette époque ce
n'était pas comme ça et c'est à
elancourt que l'ingénieur de formation
exploitera ses connaissances et
capacités en matière d'urbanisme
c'est aussi dans cette ville qu'il
connaîtra des années compliquées en plus
d'un ministère qui lui échappe à la fin
des années 80 sur fond de tensions
socialistes ils encaissent une défaite
inattendue lors des élections
législatives de 1993 face à jean-michel
fourgous alors qu à bois d'arcy on est
aux anges les sympathisants sont en
liesse à l encours la déception envahi
le visage des proches sympathisants de
guy malandain
une déception que guy malandain a su
faire sienne avec humour
itinéraire d'une défaite inattendue la
politique c'est comme ça ce sont des
victoires et des défaites il faut jamais
attendre en politique le remerciement de
ce qu'on a fait pour ses concitoyens
dans l'immédiat je vais chercher du
travail
c'est aussi simple que ça du travail
guy malandain ans cherchera pas
longtemps en 1995 il quitte elancourt
pour rejoindre trappe
le début d'une longue histoire avec
cette ville particulière connue pour ses
artistes et ses problèmes de sécurité
une ville dont il est le maire depuis
2001 si on n'a pas envie cet engagement
aller serrer la main au marché comment
ça va et cetera pas être élu et lui
attrape amanda particulier c'est un
mandat piège au sens de au sens que ça
n'arrête pas c'est les citations sont
permanentes en tout genre mais mais mais
mais c'est un piège qui nous passionne
réélu en 2008 et 2014
guy malandain a changé profondément le
visage de la commune depuis 17 ans avec
une priorité mis sur la rénovation
urbaine reste un chantier majeur dans
les cartons depuis vingt ans celui de
l'enfouissement partiel de la nationale
10 les travaux devraient débuter en fin
d'année les élections à trappes sont
dominés par les sujets de l'urbanisme et
de la sécurité c'est la nationale 10 et
sur l'aménagement en attendant une
hypothétique déviation au large trappe
par la 12 20 ans dans un pays pour faire
un projet de 100 millions d'euros qui
traverse une ville de 30 mille habitants
ça pose bien des questions
on fait les fouilles archéologiques en
janvier ont commencé les dévoiements de
réseaux tous les tracés par terre et
c'est pour moi c'est ces partis ne
savait pas dire que se régler mais c'est
parti les travaux pour la n10 parti et
guy malandain lui ne part pas au pays du
président de 40 ans celui qui fêtera ses
81 ans en juin prochain ne s'interdit
pas un nouveau mandat en 2020